compter de demain. L'entreprise
de Montréal, Saint-Félix et
Paul. Voici la suite avec Nabih
Alexandre Chartier.
♪8♪ ♪
- Envie de dépaysement?
Le Planétarium de Montréal
vous invite à partir en orbite
à bord de la Station spatiale
internationale.
OLIVIER HERNANDEZ, directeur,
Planétarium Rio Tinto Alcan
- Lorsque j'ai vu pour
la première fois les images
qu'ils avaient obtenues,
je me suis dit : Ouf! ça,
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
absolument qu'on ait au
Planétarium. La chance que
l'on a au Planétarium, c'est
de pouvoir vivre une expérience
immersive en groupe.
- David St-Jacques et
ses collègues s'adressent
directement à la caméra.
Ils racontent leur quotidien
et les défis à relever
pour habiter dans l'espace.
FÉLIX LAJEUNESSE, cofondateur,
Félix & Paul Studios
- On a vraiment voulu,
dans ce projet-là, se rapprocher
des astronautes, faire sentir
au spectateur qu'il était pas
un spectateur, mais qu'il était
un membre de l'équipage.
- Ces images ont également été
utilisées pour l'exposition
immersive "L'infini"
qui est toujours à l'affiche
du Centre d'art contemporain
Arsenal à Montréal.
- Ça a été tellement complexe,
d'une certaine façon, d'aller
chercher ces images-là.
Et c'est un projet qu'on a
tourné pendant presque trois ans
à l'intérieur et plus récemment
à l'extérieur de la station
spatiale. Donc, quand on ramène
ça sur Terre, il y a quelque
chose de précieux là-dedans
et on veut s'assurer que
le plus grand nombre de gens
possible puissent vivre
cette expérience-là.
- Le Planétarium nous invite
à prendre un peu de hauteur
et à regarder la vie terrestre
autrement.
- La station spatiale
et la planète Terre, ce sont
nos deux espaces pour la vie,
c'est les deux seuls espaces
qui existent dans l'Univers
où les humains peuvent vivre
pour le moment. Ça nous permet,
nous, de se dire : Bien,
notre planète, il faut aussi
en prendre soin et la protéger
parce que c'est un plus gros
vaisseau spatiale, mais qui est
tout aussi fragile.
- "Voyageurs stellaires :
la vie en orbite" nous amène
à l'intérieur de la station
spatiale, alors que le prochain
film qui sera présenté à partir
de 2022 nous permettra de sortir
dans l'espace avec une caméra
placée au bout du bras canadien.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M